always remember the universe has a way
of leading into where you're supposed to
be at the moment you're supposed to be
there let's do this took me 20 years to
find you how many people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes be perfect for this job you
really think a black suit is going to
solve all your problems
no but looks damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just a spooky time to prove
yourself agent M welcome to it might be
you will be with agent peach one of the
best ever to wear this suit catching up
on my daily meditation time for lunch oh
thank you hungry it's 9:30
Tuesday's taco day we've been
compromised it's every citizen of this
planet at risk
[Applause]
[Music]
if you could all just describe here just
try
really fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like the tables of 10
[Music]
[Applause]
you